they were germany's worst floods for
decades reshaping the landscape and
shifting german politics
forged in their wake a massive voluntary
movement to rebuild and recover
in the absence of enough government help
we headed for the flood zone with
volunteers not exactly fired up by
looming elections
none of the candidate is fully
convincing if somebody was joking if
angel america would be still up for
election [ __ ] probably will
because people will say well
you know we've seen the alternatives
we better stay with what we had
this was the town of arvaila in july
ravaged by the devastating floods two
months on the cleanup goes on but a
bitterness remains and the water came
from from this side so i was so
frightened the politicians they say have
let them down
we're disappointed that we're
alone here with this mess
we just can rely on the volunteers and
this should not be like this
the floods have taken a political toll
the man on the left is armin lashed new
leader of angela merkel's party and this
is him sniggering in the background
during a speech honoring the flood's
victims
pictures that saw him plummet in the
polls
among volunteers in one flood damaged
home they had little time for lashit or
politicians in general
he didn't bring money to them
the only blah blah
and in the background he is laughing
with his friends
with his
workmates
what did he think of that
very bad it's very bad
but germans must find a politician to
replace angela merkel after 16 years
dominating german and global politics
she's standing down the world is losing
its most powerful woman and germans are
bracing themselves for life without
merkel
even young campaigners against merkel's
party admit it will be strange without
her
she's been the only chancellor i've ever
known um i can't really remember time
before her so i think it's going to be a
really really big change but it is they
say time to move on
16 years of
chancellorship is too much i'd say
is there anyone to replace her though uh
yes of course
we have our candidate olaf schultz i can
show him
so we definitely say that there is
someone who can replace her and other
people say he's a bit boring he has no
charisma he is
he's boring yes i i i admit but
maybe that's the german way of politics
if they want that kind of politics this
is the man for the job can you really
replace angela merkel as chancellor
do you think if you got what it takes
can we do that later it will be a
successful election for the social
democratic party
what difference can you make in
relations with britain do you hope if
you become chancellor
we will have good relations between eu
and britain
he may not be a man of many words but
olaf schultz has brought his party back
from the political dead and could soon
lead it to victory
he's not known for charisma or political
pizzazz but in uncertain times like
these that may be what germans are
looking for making olaf shorts possibly
the man at the moment
if germans want solid stability they may
have found their candidate just don't
expect too much excitement dominick
waghorn sky news saar louis